-You know
our first guest tonight
from movies like "This Is 40,"
"Anchorman"
and Marvel's "Ant-Man."
You can catch him in
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX November 19th.
He also stars
in "The Shrink Next Door,"
with new episodes available
to stream
on Apple TV+ every Friday.
Please welcome back to the show,
our good friend,
and "People" magazine's
Sexiest Man Alive.
It should be noted...
[ Cheers ]
...not that it would've
made a difference,
I did not submit this year.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not saying
it would have changed anything.
[ Laughter ]
Please welcome our friend
Paul Rudd!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show!
-Thanks so much.
-Congratulations on this.
[ Both laugh ]
I feel like it's a weird thing
for us to talk about,
so that's gonna be
the end of it.
-Fine with me.
We can finish --
-Okay, great.
I'm very proud of you.
I'm very happy.
I'm not --
And, again, it's not, like,
a thing between us.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, I -- yeah.
It's just an honor
that they got it right.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I thought that was very sweet
that you framed it like that.
-Thank you.
Um, so I feel as though
we have been --
I feel like we --
feel like we've had you --
we've been lucky to have
Paul Rudd
in our lives for forever.
But I don't remember when
I first became aware of you.
What was your first TV job?
Or was it a film job?
What was first?
-It was a television show
called "Sisters."
-Okay.
-Yeah, I was about 22, I think.
-And what was --
Was it immediate success?
Like, when I was a young actor,
I thought if you had a sitcom,
immediately, the money,
that changes your life.
-Well, it didn't.
-Okay.
-But it was a show that existed.
It was by the guys
that did "Thirtysomething."
It was about these four sisters,
and I came on, like,
kind of late in the show
and only did a few episodes,
really.
But it was exciting.
But it was such a --
it was such a crazy thing.
I had no money.
I was living
with a couple buddies.
My car was terrible.
It would always break down.
And so when I think about it,
I just think back
to my roommate, Bo,
who more often than not,
would have to drive me to work
because my car
was always in the shop.
And we were 21, 22.
And nobody gets up
at 5:00 in the morning
when you're 21 or 22.
[ Laughter ]
He was furious.
And so we had this deal where --
He had horrible morning breath.
I mean, like,
morning breath that was so --
Like, you could smell it
in the hallway.
[ Laughter ]
And so we would get in his car,
and he was so mad
that he had to drive me
that the deal was
he was allowed to breathe
in my face for one minute...
[ Laughter ]
...and I had to take it.
I had to --
And I tried not to throw up.
And then we would drive to...
-So, not really what you
think of when you picture, like,
making it in Hollywood.
-No. Not at all.
He was furious about it.
One time, I got my car back,
and I was driving to work,
and it broke down.
And I thought,
"I can't -- I can't call him."
Because this might end
the friendship.
It was getting --
It was really --
And there was no Uber then.
This was in Los Angeles.
It was tough to get a taxi.
-That's a very --
I mean, I should say,
a lot of people talk about
the fact that you are ageless.
I think people have to remember,
like, yeah,
when you were, like, 21, 22 --
-They had just invented cars.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was a new thing.
-Yeah. Like, there was --
They had cars, but they didn't
have mechanics yet.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
And so, yeah, there was, like,
mainly horses.
When people were still taking --
[ Laughter ]
My horse
was in the shop and, um...
But I panicked, and so I ran --
There was some person
coming out of, like, a 7-Eleven.
And I ran over to him and said,
"Do you know this show?"
And I had a script.
And I said, "I'm on this show.
This is -- This is who I play.
Can you drive me to work?"
[ Laughter ]
And he looked at me and said,
"Are you serious?"
I said, "Yeah, my car
broke down, and I don't --"
And he obviously
sensed the panic in my voice,
and I just remember he said,
"All right, man. Get in."
And he drove me -- he just
drove me to Warner Bros.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so funny,
because if that happened,
you would think this is a scam,
but you wouldn't be able to
clock what the scam is, right?
-Right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You're like,
"Well, how does this end?"
-I got to believe he just --
He said,
"My wife watches that show."
I think
that was the saving grace.
-Oh, right.
-But, yeah, He could tell
that I was really -- I was
on the verge of a real collapse.
-What about
early L.A. apartments?
I spent some time
in some pretty gnarly ones
back in my early days.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Did you have some bad --
bad seed apartments?
-Yeah. This was actually --
Same roommates.
It was really my roommate Bo
was the guy --
-You know, for a guy who did you
a lot of favors,
he's not doing great
in tonight's segment.
[ Laughter ]
-No, Bo really came --
Bo was an awesome roommate.
He's still a good friend
of mine, but he really --
We were in school together, and
that was why he was my roommate.
He lived in an apartment complex
that was so bad.
Um, I won't name the name
of the apartment complex
because you could find it.
But, uh, --
But he let me stay
in his apartment,
because I didn't even have,
really, the money
to get an apartment.
And I slept on towels
in his kitchen.
[ Laughter ]
And then --
[ Both laugh ]
And then, I finally --
I kind of scrounged enough,
I was able to get an apartment
within the complex,
but I didn't really
have much furniture.
And I found a mattress
out by the dumpster in the --
[ Audience groans ]
A mattress, and I thought,
"Sweet!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Free mattress!"
So I just took it up to my room,
and then I slept on it.
And then, the next morning,
I woke up covered in red bumps.
[ Laughter ]
How's that for
Sexiest Man Alive, huh?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Here it is.
-We'll be right back
with more from Paul Rudd.